students across the land are wrapping up
annual state tests for all the backlash
these tests spark they exist mostly in
response to a sensible expectation that
parents know how their schools are doing
we should neither abandon testing nor
ignore its problems but ensure that it's
used responsibly
here are four thoughts on how to do just
that first reading and math sports can
go up or down for lots of reasons why
scores go up matters as much as whether
they do second when a focus on reading
and math tests shifts time away from
other important learning we need to
weigh the costs and benefits third
reading and math tests capture only a
narrow slice of what schools are asked
to do that matters for today's state
tests don't provide meaningful immediate
feedback it's hard to blame families for
doubting the value of tests which are
more useful for grading schools than for
educating kids look testing is a
valuable tool but like any tool it's
only effective when it's used well how
do you think we can better use
standardized tests let us know when
you're coming also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI